so we got Bobby 46 year old Bobby
honey
resources for a federal government and
My Views are mine alone not
so this is the living room uh this is
where I spend most of the day
are we starting to see the problem
immediately dudes 46 lives he's gonna
get taken for it's gonna get destroyed
right not even in good shape and just
listen to what he says here in a bit
when I'm at home some of my collection
I tend to be a little bit shy so I don't
meet a lot of folks for relationship
purposes like this is
Jared do you do this is this is this
what your apartment looks like when the
senoritos come over
uh no not really I mean I've got a I've
got a nice big couch and my office is a
little bigger but yeah no my apartment's
it's a bachelor pad the guys that have
visited me can attest to that this is
this is on a different level though I
mean but
to be honest you know I'm a little bit
so let me just stop there for a sec
because this is like an important point
right he acknowledges that I'm a little
bit heavier and he's saying this is a
real negative in the United States but
what most of these guys fail to realize
is it's even more of a negative outside
of the United States right
um 60 70 of the North American
populations overweight you know it
doesn't matter what category if it's
overweight obese morbidly obese they're
just overweight they have an unhealthy
BMI so it's pretty it's it's more common
here than it is uncommon and thinking
that uh that's a negative in the United
States but that won't be a negative in
somewhere like Ukraine which happens to
be where this guy you know is chasing
tail like you get the idea right
mm-hmm
all right guys well you've now survived
two socials I congratulate all of you
for going to the third and final social
so I'm just back up here this is a real
negative in the United States
all right guys so here's our busload of
dudes that are trying to get girls in
the Ukraine this is your this is your
standard Avatar here
um the argument that I've always made
here is that look
if
and where did Jordan go there we go yeah
I'm still here remove that I'll pull it
back in a sec I mean if you can't do
well in your own country you're not
going to do better somewhere else if you
don't have gain here it's not going to
work somewhere else you're going to get
taken for
um and this is pretty much what this guy
goes through he spends ten thousand
dollars uh on this girl and I'm just
gonna skip through all this
um because there's a lot of like you
know they're framing this guy is as
basically like a super nice guy and he's
getting taken for a ride this is the
girl that he gets introduced to who
isn't even the girl that he was been
talking to uh the company's been
charging him uh I think it was ten
dollars per message back and forth on
their system because they offer
translation service
um and he ends up proposing to her
thinking that he's engaged they have a
translator sitting at the table I don't
know who this dude is maybe a rep for
the company
not even a word of English
that's not gonna work well I think I'm
engaged now so I have to say like he
thinks he's engaged now he doesn't know
where he's at you can't even talk to her
yeah and then it goes on and on and on
uh
uh these are the screenshots of all the
messages back and forth with the tour
schedule what he's spending
um now he tries another dating app site
and he hopes that it's going to come off
you know again so
I wasn't planning on playing that one
through because that's a 13 minute job
but there's one here that's seven
minutes which speaks even louder to what
normally happens here so let me throw
that one up on the screen
uh this is a dude that works in a nail
salon
title of this one is Man spent forty
thousand dollars on a woman he's never
met we'll play this one straight through
just kind of give you well
there's that
there was this uh
place I went through my brother down in
the Dominican quite a few years ago and
there was a dude that we were talking he
was American and he was telling us about
this Russian girl that was uh supposed
to be coming to the resort to to meet
him she never showed up similar sort of
story right like you know your classic
plugged in beta sends her a bunch of
money she never shows up at the resort
and he's like I I don't know you know
like I did all the right things blah
blah blah and it's like this was this
was years ago you know before I went
went through my own unplugging Journey
so I didn't really have much to offer
him aside from oh that sucks hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out